what's the system you've developed
to get on stage and have that switch
flipped because
when you came on within two seconds it's
like this guy's in a state of mind he's
in a state as we say yeah of like he's
here to perform he he knows what he's
here to do yeah there's no like
tiptoeing into it yeah so i was
wondering what do you do the five ten
minutes before or an hour before i don't
know what's your kind of like warm-up
routine yeah yeah i think you're ready
three hours before what i do is i like
to do some form of exercise and i try to
get out of
my workout workout or you're just trying
to break a sweat what are you what's
that yeah trying to do
on tour it's just about body maintenance
so i'll do
running
i'll do some pull-ups some core stuff
just stuff to get my body going right
and start breaking a sweat and what i
love about like right around minute 30
to 45
is i'll get out of my head and into my
body
and so much of life right now
getting out of your head and it's funny
i i called you randomly i was appreciate
i appreciate you picking up the phone
the other day we had a long conversation
we can get into that later but so much
of
i think what you do and what you put out
in the world and i call it like tech
twitter talk
it's all in your head intellectual it's
all just heady
anxiety-inducing stuff
ethereum's up just solana's this it's
like it's all headshit right it's not a
body feeling thing right like grounding
yourself two feet on the ground i'm here
in this moment what do i do
and so much of performance
and to be great at it
the best chappelle the best performers
they're not in their head they're in
their body they're really there right
somebody screams somebody says something
somebody heckles they're in their body
when you watch steph curry play when i
watch devin booker play these guys are
so in their body right luca is the best
at this he's in his body he's in the
he's in flow right and so luke is like a
kid and kids do this well yeah kids do
this pretty naturally i love that the
older you get the more heavy you get
which is you gotta yeah you gotta fight
that right and so
that's a great way to get out of my head
get into my body then i'll probably i
eat something um i take a shower and
then i put i put on the outfit and for
me it's like
being on stage uniform and putting on
that it feels like a uniform and like
for me it feels i wanted to feel like a
show
like from the watch to the jacket to the
pants i'm like
there's a level of confidence that you
have when you move into a room and
you're like
hey from
from my heels all the way up to my head
i'm wearing my armor right like i'm
coming correct right and you just you
carry yourself with a little bop you're
like no i feel better about myself
my isn't slouching there's no
stains on my stuff you know what i mean
like the moment i saw you today you
walked in you're wearing your tech pants
i could tell you washed them a few times
but there's some stains on the back side
you know what i'm saying but that
feeling of like no man when i'm coming
in here i'm gonna be fresher than sean
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm just gonna
be fresh yeah
that already gives me a feeling of like
confidence i know what i'm doing you
know and and by the way the opener
marcela like marcella was just like
dressed to the nines you know this is
it's a feeling
then i get to the show um i finish
eating i'll meditate
so
meditation for 10 to 15 minutes allow me
to just again get out of my head
and drop into my body and something
simple just head space like i'm not
getting too crazy about it um and what i
love about
head space specifically is so much of it
is just basic breathing
establishing a level of intention
i'll meditate then i'll pray
and for me like prayer is really
important because it's got to be about
something bigger than just myself and my
corporal being i'm like what am i doing
this for
and just establishing an intention and
for me the intention is like love
let me give joy to people right and
i want the seed of everything that i'm
doing to come from that not be like not
be petty energy
angry energy
um i'm gonna prove you
wrong energy like
i'm in the laughter business
like i'm here to make you feel joy right
um and that warm feeling so establishing
an attention there i get to the
i'll get to the venue about an hour
before
i have a double shot of espresso
um i'll let my bowels do what they do
you always get those jitters like you
gotta pee you gotta do what you gotta do
and then about like 30 to 45 minutes
before i like to be loose just with the
with the staff right let them know like
hey what's up how are you
door guy security guy openers right you
know what i mean another way to get out
of your head by the way yeah yeah
be with others be there yeah they're
serving others in a way yeah and then
um about a half an hour before um i'll
go to my green room i usually write it
down
i'll write down it'll just be on hotel
notepad paper hey what are a couple new
tags
that i'm working on tonight right just
move the ball forward a little bit
remind myself yo i'm gonna do this
um
for example last night one of the things
i talk about act one of the show was
fertility and a new joke that i did was
like you know what it's like being
infertile as a man
i felt like woody and toy story when his
arm got ripped off
that was a that was just one line and i
was like hey make sure you do the woody
toy story line right you know
and uh
every show i try to add a few of these
extra moments
and you add that up over the course of
like a year two years three years you
start to see what works and what doesn't
work and i'll i'll have a thousand three
thousand different variations of that
right
and then i get on stage and by the time
i get on stage there's just this feeling
of like
now it's just pure play
whatever happens happens right and um
when i'm on stage what i try to do is i
try to remember
when
when i'm opening in front of my crowd
they're like really hot
and one of the things i try to remember
is
don't yell don't scream
try to actually bring them to you
like set the tempo of the game right
don't get like too excited or too hot
like you can whip them up but then like
sit down at the stool bring them to you
and like make the room feel like it's
coming to you
you know what i'm saying do you ever
watch uh film of yourself basically yeah
i watch tape all the time yeah and so i
see bad habits it's kind of brutal huh
yeah
yeah but it's cool though actually like
those moments where you like
is very painful for your ego
but there's a lot of growth in that the
only way to break through and get to
like the next part is is that part